welcome to this video this is some part
two of the series about battling and
fighting the London system as Black
London system being this well-known set
up so white plays Bishop f4 and usually
follows up with EC and c3 this very
solid system that you encounter rather
often in part one I did explain these
structures where black has committed to
d5 usually I'll move one even so d4 d5
and this video the second one will be
about Bishop f4 against the g6 setup so
I'm like usually going from a King's
Indian or or Grune field with Knight f6
g6 and white declines any invitations to
a mainline billionaire plays Bishop f4
and in general there are various move
orders that white can go for I can play
it in this way you could also even go
Bishop F here for here on move to if you
are play m g6 the Kings any kind of
setup or gue thought you can just do
this here you have the additional option
of also playing a move like d5 and
transposing into the setups that I
mentioned in the first video but in
general what I'm going to suggest
against them in this position with g6
you can also play if they should be
force played on move three move - it
doesn't really matter so I always
recommend the same setup like of course
starts with completing his son his
castling this is some one way to do it
white usually plays III castles and he M
usually h3 or Bishop e2 let's say h3 I
don't really want to go into those move
order issues there are some ways to
tribe
to exploit certain move orders by white
um but I never really bothered to look
at this to be honest I just want one set
up that I can play against this and then
there are ways to try to punish white
for example um for not playing h3 though
like giving a retreat square so the
early bishop age five and nine a 4h five
for example might be an idea at some
positions but um this is also one issue
why white sometimes delays Knight f3
but for this for the setup that I'm
recommending it's completely unimportant
if white plays h3 first a e3 first or
whatever it doesn't really matter
actually I'm going to recommend it two
setups one which is more strategic and
more positionally inclined in one
aggressive setup this led might suit
Kings Indian players better the
positionally motivated setup that I
played on myself often a c5 which
usually gets answered by C 3 and then b6
so black is playing a kind of double
fianchetto against um the London and
this very often leads to a position like
this it's very very common this kind of
position which is more often encountered
with colors reversed and then this would
be a mainline Reggie system against them
with wides where in which black has
played this Bishop f5 Bishop e7 setup
known as the the Laska setup which is
nothing else than the London with the
colors reversed and this is a good
choice if you err
um yeah a strategical player wants to
keep keep the pieces on and try to make
small kinds of maneuvers and trying to
progress slowly a good thing about this
setup is that all pieces them
say on the board there's nothing
exchanged so it's not really an adult
position it's not a position that leads
to a direct confrontation but it can get
sharp later and you have got all the
pieces on the board it's not like a
simplified position where the opponent
can just swap off pieces in fact this
London system quite often leads to tense
positions later you just need to keep
the pieces on the board as black and try
to find some way to imbalance the
position it's not not a particularly
great setup if you ask me for why to
play for a draw because you don't
simplify the position or make it easier
for you to play you only are able to
play like ten moves without thinking but
then you need to come up with a plan and
it's not so easy to find a constructive
plan for white in this kind of positions
so this would be in the positional way
to play there are tons of tons of games
to show our ideas one idea for black is
for example Quincy 7 Bishop c6 Queen B 7
and then B 5 these typical kind of ready
maneuvers on and I suggest to look at
games also with Calais reversed so this
is a good setup if you want to want a
longer game with the more strategical
field but in this position you also have
an very aggressive setup and this would
be start starting with d6 and now
whatever white place it doesn't really
matter basically white can play c3
Bishop b2 or c4 let's say it plays
Bishop e2 it's it's really the same all
the time and this is the key move Knight
F to d7 this is a setup that that I like
very much it's it's very straightforward
black prepares c5 and you can ask them
ok white why move the knight again it
has a specific idea black ones to play
d5 very quickly and he wants to make
sure that he five is really a strong
point that cannot easily be attacked by
white or let's say that white White's
pressure cannot really
much against this and we can see what
what's happening let's say castles c5
bishop h2 and Knight to c6 this was the
idea the night goes to c6 actively
putting pressure on d4 so white has got
quite some pressure on d4 now and one
point is that this a five point is very
securely protected you don't need to
move it in the near future and this is a
good thing as with the pawn on e5 being
a very very secure the h2 bishop can get
in the long run can get a bad piece
because it simply always bites on this
opponent doesn't do much like that needs
to be very careful with removing this
pawn on e5 like advancing at all or
taking on the form in this position here
on White has two principle choices um
done most active choice and probably the
best one is c4 this however it's a move
that requires some knowledge by white
probably or he simply doesn't recognize
that he's sacrificing a pawn like now
could if he wants play this and play
Queen f6 sacrificing this pawn I mean
black will win the d4 pawn but then this
um in fact isn't entirely clear white
can play Knight c3
94 I just want to put it on the board
quickly and now move like this and it's
not clear if black really benefited from
all this the c7 pawn is hanging and yeah
you cannot move it really because then
g6 is hanging and I mean maybe you need
to move it but it's not something that
you'd like to do um how to how to say
what black should play in fact I
wouldn't recommend to wrap the pawn at
all my recommendation would be simply to
to keep the pawn on e5 and continue with
f5
and this is in fact rather aggressive f
593 and here you can yak and choose you
can in this position advance e4 but be
aware that this is somewhat risky
because it improves this Bishop and
these cans of c4 c5 might make this bush
it very strong and let's just let's just
move this quickly
if white now if black now is not
cautious
then this c5 move might be an issue
attacking the pawn and activating all
the pieces so you can play this but it
is it's tricky in fact I like it I like
the idea to simply keep the pawn on e5
of course as long as you have those two
knights you cannot develop the bishop
but it's not so bad here anyway so um
you can you can even think about a
waiting move like King on the side and
then probably even think about G v g5
g4 f for various attacking ideas this is
this is playable for black and needs two
rather complicated complicated play it's
a quite funny M by the way that in this
position a top engine like Houdini likes
d5 for white and 97 and gives white um a
pretty distinct advantage which of
course is absolute nonsense like as
black is better here
I mean better than in any usual king's
linear because this is simply very
stupid piece and black is yeah black is
better you know it cannot cannot be
worse possibly if black would be worse
here than the King's Indian must be a
complete complete rubbish opening so d5
is a fun mistake by the computer um yeah
white needs to keep the pawn on d4 of
course yeah impossible continuation
would be something like group b1 and
attacking b4 b5 and black as mentioned
can go g5
you still can play before I mean ping
ajaita sir useful move anyway so this
will lead to very double-edged play
whiteboard ones on the King side and the
Queen side and black on the King side
and we have a pretty typical scenario
for the four Kings Indian wet sharp can
of raid situation with both sides are
checking on their flanks whether
stronger end you need to delicately
combine defensive measures and and
active measures to get to get a good
game I think this setup is pretty good
against the London here and it can also
be applied them against similar setups
by the way if we return let's say this
kind of stuff then white now please push
up F form this is in fact um not not a
bad setup for white and you could also
play this like d6 97 and if I've to come
it can easily transpose even let's say
something like this and yeah we start to
recognize this position can easily
transpose this is also a good weapon
against this kind of Bishop f4 setup um
and what I mentioned briefly in passing
white can can start with this move
instead of 9 f3 but in fact it doesn't
really it doesn't really change change
things let's say something like this and
now white yeah he can he can do all
these moves earlier and in this way I'm
address the night oops the knight h5
idea what I'm talking about is white
sometimes place in this way because
let's say um let's say something oops
not e3 of course you should for Bishop
g7 III and let's say something like this
cm
this is a possible line that is
completely rude out with the with
keeping the night on g1 for a while and
this is why white sometimes place this
oops very sloppy with my Museum h3 and
now of course a knight h5 you can just
drop it back or from black would do it
here can play something like this and
now g5 is ridiculous as you can just
just take here so these are some muth
all the tricks here but for the setup I
mentioned and they actually both set up
that I mentioned it's completely
unimportant how white begins you can
always set up the pieces in this way um
yeah that that's it pretty much you
don't really know need to to know more
this is just a matter of those those two
setups which lead to a fine game for
blank I think this b6 setup the ready
setup is rather solid the other one is a
bit more risky but you'll get them to
get interesting double edged to play I
think with this not ft-7 setup just to
show it once more this idea be 596 and
and following work with FF 5 later even
I think this is pretty good
in fact I sometimes play the London
system myself with white and in blitz
and especially in bullet games where you
need to dash out moves quickly and
sometimes I even play it without really
intending to do it just because you on
autopilot and Entering moves and this is
a setup which I always have problems
against because it's rather aggressive
and white doesn't have a clear plan so
I'm a good way to play as black yeah I
hope you enjoy it the final part will be
about just quickly the final part third
part will be about setups where like is
committed to an early 6
and very often would continually Queen's
Indian kind of fashion and this will be
the third part post-its - yeah thanks
for watching